mgm are planning a new series of star
game but are they already thinking about
a second series too
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so as you may know if you are a regular
to the channel i have been talking to
contacts with mgm they have been telling
me about things that are being kicked
around the office at the moment while
they're in this legal quagmire waiting
for the amazon sale to go through and
they're kicking lots of little ideas
around so that when the sale goes
through they can kickstart big projects
like stargate straight away
one of the things they're already
thinking about is stargate movies tv
series but they're also not just
thinking about an initial series they're
also thinking about a prequel series
hollywood loves a prequel i'm personally
not a big fan i think prequels kick
cannon to death i think the writers
can't help themselves they can't stay
within the confines of what is already
true and they have to change stuff
star trek is riddled with cannon errors
because of
these prequels and
time travel episodes and everything else
they try to use to explain it
in this case they are thinking about
doing an ancient prequel
now this has me intrigued intrigued but
i actually put a poll on my channel and
i asked everybody what do you think if
they do an ancient prequel series could
it work
70 odd people said yes brilliant i love
it fantastic let's crack on a few people
are kind of with me prequels are
generally bad please don't do it and a
few people just went you know i don't
care
but actually 75 of people are very very
excited about this idea the main reason
being that there are so many stories to
potentially tell
and that is what really has me
interested
but also we were potentially talking
about millions of years before the
stargate series
the ancients left the milky way five or
ten million years ago
to go to the pegasus galaxy
that is long enough really that you can
tell stories back then without it
destroying canon now even with
a tiny bit of concentration and a tiny
bit of love for the original series you
can create new stories in an ancient
time frame that don't pee all over
existing canon
we could see stories about the ancients
on celestis
their conflict with the ori that made
them leave that galaxy and come to the
milky way galaxy in the first place we
could see stories about the great plague
that swept through the milky way and
nearly wiped all life out to the point
where the ancients built the great super
weapon under cara a weapon that was
actually used to reignite life within
the milky way galaxy
we could see stories about dissena the
original city starship that was on
dakara
i'd love to see stories about how the
first stargates were built or how the
destiny was built and what the real
project for that was this actually might
be a really nice way of closing the loop
on the sgu series and actually answering
a lot of the questions that we still
have about the destiny and where it was
going what it was doing
and of course after the ancients left
the milky way to go to the pegasus
galaxy we could see stories about the
great battle with the wraith atlantis
was apparently onlantia for 45 000 years
before it was abandoned there are
hundreds of stories that we could see
that could feed into episodes we have
that could explain episodes of stargate
sg1 and stargate atlantis how many times
do we come across ancient technology
that we could actually see some
background for and that would help us
understand the ancients far better than
we currently do
to be honest
i'd quite like to see this maybe as um a
series that has like little special
episodes that drop in and out of lots
and lots of different storylines you
know different actors and different
characters each week or maybe lots of
little mini series saying like five
episode mini series or something that
tells a little different story in a
completely different time frame you
could really jump between three galaxies
that we know the ancients have been in
my excitement for this project really is
based around the fact that there are so
many stories and so many ideas that they
could follow that could use technology
and use have a feel for the show that
we're used to but beset generally
millions of years ago
it could ask new questions but answer
old ones as well
i actually think that this could be a
prequel that i actually would like to
see and i've never actually said that
before
do i think amazon would actually do it
yeah look what they're doing at the
moment with the lord of the rings
they're spending a billion quid to
produce a prequel that is set thousands
of years before the books
that's going to do exactly what i'm
talking about with stargate project
it's not a new idea
everybody does prequel series star trek
star wars
and soon stargate so well
let's not forget actually that we've
already had kind of a prequel series in
stargate origin so it's not even new for
the stargate franchise
but what do you think leave me a comment
tell me what you think tell me if this
is a series you actually want to see and
if you do what sort of stories do you
want to come out of it this is all very
reliant on the fact that stargate does
for one get green lit which is still not
100 confirmed and is popular enough that
it warrants a second series
but if it happens
are you excited about it leave a comment
you can also join the channel small
contribution every month it helps me
create more content
you can join us on facebook as well and
start the conversation with me and other
sidetrackers the links in the
description
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you really soon